Speaker 1: I have to tell you, there are stories
we do on this show, which are extremely multifaceted
in terms of what they mean geopolitically,
sociologically, all these different things.
And sometimes there is just a story that is
too funny at an absolute basic level.
You all know about the Big Lie at this point.
I'm sure this is the lie that Joe Biden didn't
really win the 2020 election.
Donald Trump really won it.
It's something Trump and his followers have
been pushing really since even before the
2020 election, talking about mail in ballot
fraud before the election even took place.
No evidence for any of it.
But then they really got going with this stuff
on election night, when Trump came out at
2:00 a.m. and said, We've basically won, it's
over.
When that wasn't the case, and of course,
a couple of days later, it was confirmed,
actually, Joe Biden is the one who won.
The claims range widely from they stole votes
digitally with hackers or who knows dead people
voted the mail in ballots were fraudulent.
All these different ideas, no evidence for
any of it.
Of course, over the weekend, the former president
put out another one of these unhinged statements,
which now are appearing really just on his
website because he's banned on Twitter and
he's banned on Facebook and all of it.
And it actually is.
I would argue, I'm going to propose to you
this is the most unifying statement that Donald
Trump has ever made as a result of grammatical
error.
There's really no other way to put it.
Donald Trump's statement says, and I'm just
going to read it to you as written, and then
we're going to unravel the grammar of it.
You really have to pick it apart, Trump says.
Anybody that doesn't think there wasn't massive
election fraud in the 2020 presidential election
is either very stupid or very corrupt.
This is a Trump statement I can agree with.
Now, let's break it down.
We you have to really take apart the grammar.
OK, so Trump says anybody that doesn't think
there wasn't fraud is corrupt or stupid.
So if Trump had said, Imagine this is the
way I unravel these double negatives.
If Trump had said anybody that thinks there
wasn't fraud is stupid, that's really easy.
You don't think there's fraud.
You're stupid.
When Trump
Speaker 2: says anybody
Speaker 1: that doesn't think there wasn't
fraud, Trump is saying, if you believe that
there's fraud.
If you believe the big lie, that's a double
negative, you're stupid or corrupt.
And that is exactly right.
It actually I was looking over the weekend,
I was saying, OK, so if you don't think it
wasn't, this is a statement that I agree with.
Now, sure.
Double negative phrasing is kind of weird.
But Trump is finally correct about something
here.
And this is, of course, the ultimate cellphone
saved by syntax, bizarrely enough, and it's
surreal in some weird way.
When you think that this guy had the nuclear
codes for four years, could this be the subconscious
truth that Trump actually believes that if
you've fallen for his lies, you are the stupid
or corrupt one?
Just Trump simply have no idea how double
negatives work, and in a sense, it's the perfect
unifying message if you're able to unravel
the double negative.
The way we've just done and you understand
it, you agree.
If you're not able to unravel the double negative,
maybe you also fell for the voter fraud, lied
to begin with.
And so you also agree with the statement.
It's it's incredible that he has figured out
a way to really make a unifying statement
that just about everybody will believe and
we're supposed to believe.
That he genuinely earned good grades at the
University of Pennsylvania, so there it is.
If he does get back on Twitter, it will be
a very, very dark day.